so in the bottom here we see neon and
this is again this is a small glass
discharge tube which has got a very low
pressure of neon inside it it's
generally used for lots of signs and
things like that you might see fish and
chips or perhaps a disco or something
like that so a neon is an inert gas like
helium and it doesn't really form any
compounds at all most of you probably
seen neon because it's used in these so
called neon signs where you take a glass
tube and put a high voltage and it
produces a red light so you can see that
again a discharge of high potential
discharge is going across this tube and
it's exciting all of the neon molecules
inside such that we get this exciting
really really vivid red coloration and
skill glass blowers can blow this into
shapes of signs saying pizza or whatever
on shops you can freeze neon at very low
temperatures about 10 degrees absolute
and early on in my scientific career I
did do an experiment in solid neon it
produced a great result with an iron
compound and I'm still quite proud of it
several years on but it's not really
very important in terms of absolute
chemistry so this is just a simple
pocket spectroscope and it allows us to
analyze the wavelengths of light that
each of these individual light sources
is giving off so each individual atom as
it's excited and in its emission zone
can give rise to different lines or
different frequencies of radiation or
light we can use this little device to
analyze which elements are in each of
these different lights so we put it up
to our eyes and we look through and we
look at the different colors of the
lines in the different gases